for the past decade and a half China has
been the engine for the world economy
sucking in oil concrete and commodities
and spewing out trillions of dollars of
goods for the engine is now starting to
stutter so what's happened well it turns
out that much of the country's growth
was built on credit borrowing a lot of
it funded big construction projects but
then the housing markets slumps so
Beijing encourage people to put their
money in shares instead but debt can
only get you so far and soon enough the
stock market crashed as well China's
economic growth is now slowing and the
authorities are doing whatever they can
to keep the cogs turning because weaker
growth means more chance of civil unrest
what are those measures well they're
cutting interest rates banning short
selling in stock markets and
dramatically devaluing its currency you
can feel the impact already whether
that's in the companies trying to sell
luxury goods to China or the oil price
which is down partly because of less
Chinese demand but some economists still
think China is heading for a japan-style
slump bad news for the rest of us who
have been used to having that engine
behind us